[Musique]
non
oui chérie tu joues avec lila tu sais
c'est un peu comme sa soeur vous faites
partie de la même famille maintenant
allez on se débrouille très bien tous
les deux un
on a besoin de personne nous ben ouais
bon on soit jenga où on va jouer une
petite voiture doit aimer toi je
m'occupe de mes équipes sur lesquelles
françois poisson
qu'est ce que tu fous dans ma chambre
alors je voudrais pas de contrarier un
mais je pense que désormais ce sera
notre chambre
vu que avec les leurs on va s'installer
ici comme ça ben on est une famille
maintenant en famille qu'est ce que tu
as ma fait vachement mal à la gorge
oui enfin des excuses on a pas mal nous
commençons à nous ban ou les amis
imaginaires on a pas mal d imaginer un
c'est quoi ça on ne dit pas que tu
penses que tu est réel bon c'est quitter
parents à cheval et une mangouste il ya
un ketchup
je suivais ça se marie pas ok
qu'est ce que tu fais ton travail ça
dépend ça dépend des jours ça dépend d
après midi
parfois je suis pirates le moment je
suis caissière même que des moments je
fais comme le papa de l'île âge j'ai
créé des chiffres sur des feuilles
comptable quoi alors pas tout à fait à
ce que nous avec lila on dit chiffrier
même que tu peux aller lui demander
elle sait qui je suis oui mais c'est
normal puisque c'est elle qui taclait
c'est comme moi c'est une eau et qui m'a
t attends tu peux répéter
tiens ça par exemple j'ai déjà vu un
chiffrier aller qu'ils refusaient en a
pas des masses
voilà parce que ça n'existe pas tu
n'existes pas poisson
mais
oui moi non plus je n'existe pas et je
voulais pas dire ça comme ça aussi tu
sais au début j'ai eu du mal à
l'accepter et puis bah plus doit être la
chance tu es tellement refusait rien est
vachement bien franchement j'adorerais
en avoir une tu peux faire plaindre des
amis imaginaires qui sont là pour jouer
avec les enfants quand ils sont seuls
sinon il est dit là il se met à jouer
ensemble non ça plus rien non mais si on
sert à rien ce petit roman disparaître
exactement
on va disparaître
[Musique]
absolument qu'on laisse en paix se jouer
ensemble d'accords faire ça c'est pas
bien l'attendrissement a trouvé une idée
une idée je sais on va faire un gros
trou dans le public est là avec un grand
c o comme ça ça a nourri qui sera en
anglais non ça c'est pas une bonne idée
ça n'a qu'à faire un shampoing et de la
confiture est là et bien on lui coupe
les cheveux avec les ciseaux et ça c'est
marrant n'ont pas les cheveux paca des
mollahs le château fort en lego tu
touches pas de château fort on a mis
trois jours à le monter s'atténue guerre
ou alors on demande aux enfants de faire
manger de la mayonnaise ou à me taire
ah ouais mais non ça marchera pas parce
que si c'est les deux qui me font se
rend complice et j'étais présent
françois poisson il est drôle il est
grand il a institué un profit 0 ça c'est
moi à moi si monsieur bart mail en
suisse
il a un tutu et va jouer aux pirates de
roquettes
[Musique]
bref c'est la fin ouais
j'emprunte disparaître regarde champ
plus mes jambes serrées mais là c'est
fini centration ensemble c'est philippe
maury d'artois ya une certaine logique
tu sais nous les amis imaginaires on est
là pour accompagner disparaîtrait et si
on est terminée caméra joue avec nous
allez
[Musique]